so
[Music]
this
is the world of the microbe
a world discovered in a drop of water
under the lens of the first microscope
[Music]
the men who first brought this world
into focus
wondered what it meant
and where its creatures came from
but the only result of their
speculations
was a catalogue of strange monsters
[Music]
and to explain their appearance
they revived the theory that primitive
forms of life were generated
spontaneously
out of air and decaying matter
for nearly two centuries
until 1857
science came no closer to an
understanding of the microscopic world
but in that year
chemist louis pasteur
proved that microbes were the sole cause
of the fermentation process
that ferments were living organisms
which decompose matter as they fit on it
multiplying by budding
till they had chemically transformed
what they fell on
[Music]
it was a revolutionary concept
the first major clue to the riddle of
the microscopic world
[Music]
bye
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but where did these beings come from
pasteur believed they were transported
by the dust in the air
when they landed amid conditions
favorable to their growth they began to
feed and multiply
increasing their own kind a billion-fold
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to test this theory
pasteur devised a simple experiment
he pumped air from outside his window
through a filter of cotton
then he dissolved the cotton and alcohol
leaving only the dust particles that
were trapped in it
[Music]
these he suspended in a drop of
distilled water and examined under a
microscope
and there
amid the scattered particles of dust
were indeed the remains of living
organisms
faster presented his findings before the
french academy of sciences
spontaneous generation is a mere
illusion
the microbes which appear to come out of
nowhere where in reality carried there
by the atmospheric dust
but pasteur's opponents were unconvinced
they regarded the theory as preposterous
the experiments as vague and inclusive
back in his tiny laboratory pasteur
determined to settle for all time the
question of where germs originate
preparing a liquid suitable to the
growth of microbes he boiled it
thoroughly to destroy all life within it
a platinum tube which was attached to
the neck of the flask was then heated to
a very high temperature
when the air had been driven from the
flask by the boiling
he turned off the flame to allow it to
cool
thereupon air began to flow back into
the flask but as it passed through the
red-hot platinum tube
all the microbes carried by the air were
instantly burned up
thus both the air and the liquid in the
flask were entirely free of living
matter
pasteur immediately sealed it with a
flame and allowed it to stand at a
temperature most favorable to the growth
of microbes
yet no life appeared in the flask it was
entirely sterile
pasteur then performed the experiment in
reverse
using the filter of non-inflammable
material this time he sterilized it then
pumped air through it by the same method
as before
this filter which was completely sterile
except for the dust particles drawn out
of the air
pasteur paste in the flask that was used
in the previous experiment and had shown
no sign of life
the flask was immediately resealed and
allowed to stand at the same temperature
as before
this time
the liquid began to cloud up
out of the dust particles imprisoned in
the filter a mold comprising billions of
organisms
emerged soon
it was a swarm with living matter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
to show that the filter itself could not
have produced this growth he repeated
the experiment
leaving out the dust particles
again the liquid was unchanged
but pasteur's opponents now found a new
objection
when you heated the air you killed it
creative force
pasteur's reply
was a flask with a long twisted neck
which he filled with the usual liquid
and brought to a boil
but this time instead of sealing the
flask
yet he let the air flow back
and when the dust particles attempted to
return with the air
they were stopped by the curve of the
neck
so that the unheated dust-free air could
now mix freely with the liquid yet
remain clear
pasteur then turned the flask upside
down allowing the liquid to gather up
the dust particles deposited in the neck
[Music]
and overnight it clouded up with living
matter
but pasteur's opponents were still
unconvinced
ah but if there were so many germs in
the air they would form a fog in the
atmosphere as dense as iron
to answer this argument
pasteur decided to show that the number
of germs in the air varied with the
locality
he filled hundreds of thin straight neck
flasks with identical liquids
boil them thoroughly
then seal them leaving a vacuum in each
the first location chosen for the
experiment was the dusty courtyard of
the paris observatory here a number of
the flasks were snapped open with
carefully sterilized instruments
and quickly resealed
and in every case the flasks were
invaded by microbes
[Music]
but in the cellar of the observatory
where the air being motionless carry
little dust and suspension
just too clouded up
[Music]
finally to show that the number of
microbes in the air decreases with the
altitude
he climbed a high peak in the alps and
repeated the experiment there
and of 20 flasks opened only one cowed
it up
yet the debate went on unresolved
and pastor continued to press homer's
attacks against the unyielding
opposition
[Music]
spontaneous generation is a myth
in 20 years of research i have never
found a trace of it
the air by itself cannot produce life it
is the germs in the air the germs
transported by the air that reproduce it
but while the scientists argued over his
discoveries
pasteur was using them to revolutionize
the production of french wines beer and
vinegar
and his process of using heat to destroy
harmful germs was adopted the world over
under the name of pasteurization
then a ruinous silkworm epidemic
summoned pasteur to the south of france
he knew almost nothing about silkworms
at the time
but he set up his headquarters in a
silkworm nursery and proceeded to prove
that the epidemic was a combination of
two different diseases
and that each was caused by a separate
characteristic microbe
pasteur and his colleagues then
undertook to fight the epidemic in the
field armed with microscopes they toured
the silkworm areas pointing out to the
incredulous growers the agents of the
disease
and outlining techniques for stamping
out the epidemic
when the silkworms changed to molds they
were made to lay their eggs on separate
pieces of cloth
each moth was then crushed into a paste
and examined under a microscope
if harmful microbes were detected all
the eggs laid by that moth were to be
destroyed
the unraveling of the silkworm epidemic
and the campaign in the field took six
exhausting years
before it was finished he suffered a
stroke that left him partially paralyzed
for the rest of his life
yet he continued to work
convinced that in these studies of the
microscopic world he was approaching the
secret of all infectious disease
[Music]
by 1873
pasteur was the acknowledged leader of
the two new sciences of microbiology and
biochemistry
and now
his success in stamping out the silicone
epidemic won him a place on the academy
of medicine
as a chemist untrained in medicine
pasteur had up to now hesitated to
invade the province of the medical men
now he resolved to make known his views
on the causes of infectious disease
and to campaign for reforms in
controlling them
[Music]
he began therefore to visit the
hospitals and investigate their
practices
he denounced his myths the medical
theories of the day which blamed
epidemics on mysterious mists putrid
heirs and the like
[Music]
he scolded the medical staff for
permitting infections to be spread
through unsanitary hospital beds and
dressings
[Music]
but above all
he strove to establish that standard
hospital practice as
absolute cleanliness
flaming of instruments
sterilization of dressings
and the unfailing use of antiseptics
while his opponent sneered that he was
beginning to see microbes in everything
he brought to light the microbe which
causes many of the common illnesses
the staphylococcus
and when a child dead fever epidemic
broke out from the hospitals he took the
floor at the academy
[Music]
the real cause of this epidemic is lack
of sanitation the doctors themselves
carry this disease from the sick to the
healthy
may be right
but i doubt if any of us will live to
see this microbe
but pasteur had found it
there is your microbe
this organism which resembled a string
of tiny beads was the deadly
streptococcus
pasteur turned to animal diseases to
learn more about how infections are
spread
[Music]
and his first choice was sheep anthrax
a diseased and ravaging flocks
throughout europe
[Music]
he found these rod-like microbes in the
bloodstream
then proceeded to track down step by
step the path of the infection
[Music]
when a sheep died of anthrax
the bacteria survived by forming hard
internal seeds called spores
and as the bacteria disintegrated the
spores were set free
[Music]
though buried underground with the
carcass of the dead animal the spores
were sometimes brought back to the
surface by earthworms
there they were picked up by healthy
sheep and returning to the blood they
spread the disease anew
[Music]
when the veterinarians refused to
believe that a microbe could cause
anthrax insisting that it was a disease
of the blood itself
pasteur offered this remarkable
experiment
taking one drop of blood from a sick
sheep
he mixed it with a broth favorable to
the growth of bacteria
[Music]
slowly
a poisonous growth invaded the flask
so
[Music]
24 hours later he withdrew a single drop
from this culture and mixed it with a
fresh one
[Music]
the process was repeated over and over
again
until the original drop of blood had
been diluted to the vanishing point
yet its virulence was undiminished
proof
that it was not the blood that caused
death but in microbe reproducing within
the blood
at the same time pasteur was
experimenting with many other animal
diseases
among them chicken cholera
he had isolated the tiny microbe of this
disease and found it to be invariably
fatal to chickens
then an inspired guest
led him on to one of the greatest
scientific discoveries of all time
having found by chance
an old culture of chicken color bacilli
in his incubator
it occurred to pasteur to experiment
with these weak outdated microbes
he inoculated the birds
but after becoming mildly ill they
recovered completely
[Music]
thereupon he ordered a second
inoculation
this one fresh and full strength
but to his amazement these deadly
microbes had no effect whatever the
chickens had been immunized by the
weakened organisms
it was the first experimental vaccine
following the same principle pasteur
tried to develop a vaccine for anthrax
but here a difficulty occurred
for these bacteria when aged turned to
spores
[Music]
pasteur finally solved this problem by
finding a temperature at which the
spores were unable to form
then having fully tested the vaccine
he decided to demonstrate it publicly on
a dramatic scale
at a farm called puyola 4
he gathered 50 sheep and a number of
cows
half were vaccinated the other half
remained unvaccinated
then all were to be inoculated with the
deadly bacteria of anthrax
this sensational experiment attracted a
skeptical audience from all parts of
france
most prominent of whom were the
opponents of pasteur
certain this time that he'd overreached
himself they turned out in a body
but most skeptical of all were the
veterinarians who watched every move
with suspicion anticipating a hoax
pasteur however was unruffled confident
that the vaccine already proved in the
laboratory would work as well in the
field
will you permit me
[Applause]
there you are
[Applause]
would you mind giving this one a triple
dose
not at all
monsieur
would it be possible to inoculate in
turn a vaccinated and an unvaccinated
animal
certainly if you wish
after the inoculations the animals
harvard for days between life and death
finally a pattern emerged
one by one
the unvaccinated ones died
those who were vaccinated recovered
[Applause]
it was a stunning victory for the
principle of vaccination
in a triumphant vindication of the germ
theory of disease
pastor returned to paris a national hero
[Applause]
[Music]
though rapidly failing in health
pasteur now plunged into a study of the
dread disease of rabies
because the disease is communicated
through the saliva he began by hunting
for a microbe in the mouths of rabid
dogs
although the search failed
pasteur refused to give up
surmising that the organism might simply
be too small to be detected even under a
microscope
he stopped his laboratory with rabid
dogs
and by studying the effect of this
disease on living tissue
tracked the invisible virus to the
nervous system
then removing a diseased spinal cord he
placed it in a dry jar to age till its
virulence was reduced to that of a
vaccine
[Music]
in the outskirts of paris pasteur
managed to obtain the use of a vacant
estate for another mass experiment
here in improvised kennels techniques
for immunization were perfected
under pasteur's humane care hundreds of
dogs were vaccinated and rendered safely
immune to rabies
but could the vaccine prevent
hydrophobia in a human being
the decision to experiment was forced
upon him one day by a mother and child
in distress
for the boy had been severely attacked
some days before by a mad dog
[Music]
the thought of injecting a rabid virus
into the boy was terrifying to pastor
still judging from the severity of the
bites that hydrophobia and death were
almost inevitable he agreed to vaccinate
[Music]
with most of the medical world standing
by
pasteur made a series of injections of
the untried vaccine
the dose was stepped up continuously
till on the 14th day
he could pronounce the boy
cured
hydrophobia one of the most dreaded of
all human diseases
had been conquered
pasteur died in 1895
exhausted by a lifelong struggle against
the microorganisms of disease and the
prejudice of his time
[Music]
but he had lived to see his name and
work perpetuated by a great institute of
research
the entire course of medicine recharted
by his discoveries in the world of the
infinitely small
the life-saving vaccines and antibiotics
that succeeding generations of
scientists are giving the world
were pioneered by these studies of
ferments silkworms
anthrax chicken cholera
and rabies
[Music]
but pasteur left to science
a legacy surpassing even these
it was a system
a logic
and a scientific method
which are the basis of medical research
and which promise to secure for us
the miracles
of the future
you